History is often the greatest teacher.
By looking at the past, we can learn from
it with the benefit of hindsight.
Such as in the early twentieth century, when
the entire planet was in the grip of a horrifying
war.
At the time, this conflict was often referred
to as The Great War, although there was little
“great” about it.
Others knew it as the War to End All Wars,
the largest armed engagement the world had
known, although it would not be the last.
Today, with that hindsight we just mentioned,
we know it as World War One.
In June 1914, an Archduke of Austria was shot
dead by a Serbian assassin, and as a result
of the complicated treaties forged between
various nations, soon much of the world was
involved in a war that started out as little
more than a scuffle between neighbors.
The horrors of trench warfare, the carnage
caused by the earliest chemical weapons and
armored tanks, left a permanent and lasting
scar on the world’s history, one still mourned
and remembered to this day.
The advances in chemical and mechanized warfare
that took place during World War One ranged
from the use of chemicals like tear gas used
to disable targets, to more lethal compounds
like mustard gas.
And of course, this was the first war to introduce
tanks to the battlefield.
Although these were clumsy and cumbersome
to begin with, it was arguably the advent
of the First World War that forced many advancements
in armored warfare.
It was the belief of many intellectuals on
all sides that if the Great War was made too
gruesome and horrific to continue, it would
come to its natural end.
This, of course, did not happen, only encouraging
each participant of World War One to continue
advancing their weaponry.
But what if there were weapons developed during
World War One that were too dangerous to be
deployed?
With every side looking for any advantage
over their adversaries, what if some turned
to the unethical, even the anomalous, to gain
the upper hand in the war?
Introducing SCP-186, otherwise known as To
End All Wars.
Try to imagine weaponry that was so incredibly
advanced for the mid-1910s, yet so horribly
and unjustifiably cruel.
Worse than gas that can cause blisters to
form not only on the skin but also inside
the lungs.
More advanced than armored vehicles with mounted
machine guns crawling across No Man’s Land.
It’s hard to picture something that could
be more devastating than that, especially
for the time period.
But a good measure of a weapon’s destructive
power is usually found in the damage it leaves
in its wake.
In this case, SCP-186 is exactly that; not
the anomalous weapons themselves, but the
site of a battle that took place between the
24th of July and the 13th of August in 1917.
The event became known as the Battle of Husiatyn
Woods, but you won’t find any mention of
it in the history books.
Any and all records of the battle have been
secretly expunged by the SCP Foundation, and
their own archive is now the only place where
someone can find details of what happened
over those few weeks.
The engagement took place between the German
Imperial Army and forces belonging to Russia’s
provisional government, a small skirmish in
comparison to the enormity of many battles
of the First World War.
So, what happened at the Battle of Husiatyn
Woods to make it so horrible it had to be
stricken from the historical record?
For that we have to go back to Husiatyn, a
small settlement in western Ukraine, in July
of 1917.
The surviving remnants of a Russian division
had been scattered.
The Germans’ counterattack against the Kerensky
Offensive had driven the Russian troops to
the dense forest that surrounded the town
of Husiatyn.
You might be forgiven for thinking that the
outnumbered Russian force was decimated by
almost five hundred German soldiers pursuing
them.
But you would be very, very wrong.
As the opposing forces met, they engaged each
other in a fearsome battle.
But this was unlike any encounter that had
taken place over the course of World War One,
or ever would again.
Both sides were armed with anomalous weaponry,
possessing technology beyond any that had
ever been seen at the time.
To this day, the SCP Foundation has been baffled
by these weapons.
Even with their unique understanding of the
anomalous, Foundation researchers have been
unable to replicate any of them, and instead
keeps them secured in the munitions wing of
Site-23, all under the designation of SCP-186-1.
Among the recovered instances of SCP-186-1
is a highly modified Skoda M1909 machine gun.
However, rather than behaving like a standard
firearm, this gun would cause rapid forming
growths, not unlike tumors, to appear within
the body of its targets.
Another was concertina wire, a form of spiraled
razor wire commonly used in trenches.
Only this wire was coated in an unknown compound
that caused permanent hallucination whenever
the wire cut a person and allowed the hallucinogen
to enter their bloodstream.
A number of rifle cartridges were also found
littered around SCP-186.
Sounds pretty normal for a First World War
battlefield, right?
Except these cartridges were not filled with
gunpowder like you would expect them to be.
Instead, they inexplicably contained human
bone, ground into powder.
The purpose of this ammunition, or how it
was manufactured, is still unknown to the
SCP Foundation.
As if a gun that causes tumors and hallucination-triggering
wire weren’t bad enough, Foundation researchers
also found a number of grenades used by the
troops at the site of SCP-186.
These were British Empire standard issue No.
27 grenades, but they contained a unique,
anomalous gas that was capable of passing
through any and all filters.
Gas masks were developed during World War
One to protect soldiers from mustard and tear
gas on the battlefield, but these masks only
offered basic filtration by today’s standards.
Even so, the gas contained in these grenades
was strong enough to negate any and all filtration
systems, but that was far from its worst quality.
Did this unknown gas choke troops?
Not quite.
Did it disable them like tear gas?
In a way, yes, but this gas did so by making
any soldier exposed to it experience the sensation
of having their body set on fire.
Constantly.
Also recovered at SCP-186 were the remains
of some form of explosive, and it is believed
by the Foundation that this was detonated
at the culmination of the Battle of Husiatyn
Woods, causing approximately a third of the
battle’s total casualties.
Foundation researchers estimate that almost
three hundred civilians were either caught
in the blast, or died as a result of the crossfire
between the German and Russian forces.
The soldiers involved were all also permanently
incapacitated or killed, or at least, almost
all of them.
So, where did all these anomalous weapons
come from?
And why were they used just in this battle,
not throughout the First World War?
According to records kept from the public
by the SCP Foundation, the German troops in
the Husiatyn Woods were accompanied by a Hungarian
advisor to their military named Mátyás Nemeş.
Under his orders, they specifically targeted
and tracked the Russian division that was
retreating from them, who were similarly accompanying
a French scientist, Dr. Jean Durand.
It was these two men, Nemeş and Durand, who
were responsible for arming the Germans and
Russians with their arsenals of anomalous
weapons.
They had ensured that their inventions of
death had only received limited manufacturing,
and had intentionally joined opposing sides
of the war effort to test their creations
in real combat.
In other words, it appears that Durand and
Nemeş had been working together since the
beginning of the war, and the troops they
were with had been manipulated into taking
part in a big test.
These soldiers were just as unlucky as the
civilians caught in the crossfire.
Today, the SCP Foundation has established
an automated security perimeter around the
site of SCP-186, preventing access to anyone
unless authorized.
Everything within the perimeter is frequently
patrolled and observed by security personnel.
Why the need for so much security at an old
battleground?
Given the damage caused by the use of so many
anomalous weapons, including those the Foundation
were unable to recover, the area of SCP-186
has become a hotspot for unusual happenings,
even long after the Battle of Husiatyn Woods
ended.
These anomalies include abnormal environmental
or weather conditions.
For example, all the trees in the southwestern
portion of the former battlefield died and
decomposed at an accelerated rate in 1923,
while the temperature dropped to a permanent
minus fifteen degrees Celsius four years later,
but yet there was never any snowfall.
Then there were the sounds of gunfire in 1932,
despite there being nobody inside the SCP-186
site.
A number of years later, a pair of Foundation
agents disappeared on a routine patrol of
the area, and were never seen again.
Of course, 23 years after the end of the War
to End All Wars, the world was plunged into
chaos and found itself at war once again.
During this time, SCP Foundation personnel
were instructed to evacuate the site of SCP-186,
based on intelligence from their allied operatives
who were working undercover inside the Third
Reich.
As the Foundation disembarked their observation
posts, a faint glow was visible coming from
SCP-186.
Four years passed, and the Second World War
came to a close.
The Foundation returned to re-establish their
containment of SCP-186, and immediately discovered
thirteen corpses dressed in German army uniforms,
bearing the insignia of the fourth Panzer
Army.
There were a further 27 bodies of soldiers
wearing the garb of the Soviet 22nd Army.
Both sets of bodies had already begun decaying,
although someone had removed the dog tags
and anything else that could identify these
dead troops.
It seemed that history had, to some extent,
repeated itself, as the Nazi and Soviet forces
had clashed on the same battlefield where
their German and Russian predecessors had
fought during the Battle of Husiatyn Woods.
Years later, in 1959, a large sinkhole formed
in the northeast portion of SCP-186.
Four men were found wandering nearby, all
extremely disorientated, wearing decomposing
military uniforms.
Were they lost survivors of the Nazi-Soviet
battle?
No, these men were in World War One uniforms,
German Empire and Russian standard issue.
They had survived the Battle of Husiatyn Woods,
and were somehow still standing, even though
they should have died during the First World
War.
How did these troops manage this?
Well, the final anomalous weapon recovered
at the site of SCP-186 were mortar shells,
but unsurprisingly, these weren’t your standard
high explosive artillery.
Much like those grenades mentioned earlier,
these mortar shells contained a unique, previously
unseen gas.
But instead of causing the perpetual pain
of being on fire, this gas altered the biology
of cells that it came into contact with.
Somehow, it triggered a change that prevented
a body’s cells from ceasing life function,
keeping them continuously operational.
In other words, it meant that any soldiers
exposed to the gas simply could not die.
That’s right, some of the troops involved
in the Battle of Husiatyn Woods are still
alive to this day.
The SCP Foundation immediately began excavating
the sinkhole, and discovered twenty three
bodies buried beneath in a mass grave.
They were more of the surviving World War
One soldiers, kept alive for decades by the
mortar gas.
Some of them still had infected wounds and
battlefield injuries that should have killed
them, yet their bodies refused to die.
The soldiers were rounded up and hauled off
to Site-23, where the Foundation’s researchers
began assessing them.
However, they were unable to glean any useful
information from the German and Russian troops
that had been unearthed.
All of the soldiers exhibited symptoms of
extensive psychological trauma, and had developed
various mental disorders while buried alive
under the battlefield.
They had all been driven to insanity, perhaps
as a result of their unnaturally extended
lifespans, maybe from being buried underground
and unable to die for so long.
Or perhaps it was the wartime atrocities they
witnessed that drove the soldiers over the
brink.
History is a great teacher.
But those willing to forget its mistakes are
often doomed to repeat them.
Mátyás Nemeş and Dr. Jean Durand created
the anomalous weapons responsible for SCP-186,
and similar minds would later go on to build
the atomic bomb and countless weapons of mass
destruction after.
World wars, the suffering of countless troops
and civilians, these parts of history mean
nothing if we don’t allow ourselves to learn
from them, and maybe that’s our curse as
a species, that we are doomed to fight the
war to end all wars again, and again, and
again.
Now check out “SCP-2273 - Major Alexei Belitrov”
and “SCP-1461 - House of the Worm” for
more wild, war-related SCPs!